two years while wreckage and bodies from
Air France flight 447 had been brought
to shore the mystery of what caused the
crash that killed 228 people remained
unanswered on the Atlantic sea floor
then in 2011 remote submarines at last
discovered the flight recorders they
revealed a terrifying chain of events
istop sensors repeated alarms an
apparent pilot error as the Airbus A330
plumbers it into the ocean
a 2019 ruling not to prosecute either
Airbus or Air France was overturned on
appeal last year their trial on charges
of involuntary manslaughter began
we lost our daughter Julia
and her fiancee Bose 29 years old
it was of course a lot of suffering for
our both of our families
but time heals wounds however
we still feel Justice is not done
the aircraft was approaching the equator
when it flew into a severe storm icing
up air speed sensors and disengaging the
automatic pilot the plane climbed
steeply lost speed stalled and fell nose
up toward the Atlantic recordings showed
the most Junior of the three flight crew
remained in control for most of the
final minutes of the flight as the three
men tried in vain to understand weather
then why the plane was going down
initially magistrates attributed the
crash to Pure pilot error but the
victims groups successfully argued that
both Air France and Airbus should be
prosecuted for alleged failings in Pilot
training and plane Warning Systems both
companies deny manslaughter if found
guilty it would be the first conviction
of its kind in France the maximum
penalty for these corporate Giants would
be 247
000 US dollars
Harry Fawcett I'll just